[Musique]
à
allez
pourquoi on trouvait ça
[Musique]
depuis les réformes bancaires depuis la
fin de la fonction publique depuis la
réforme du bac plus là les deux années
comme en convient c'est une catastrophe
quoi et on a l'impression de voir notre
système
mis en pièces s'est même pas une
impression d'ailleurs dans le cadre de
l'éducation nationale c'est le ministre
le plus détesté unanimement détesté par
par mes collègues fait c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir à ce point-là
fait l'unanimité contre soi je le
félicite parce que c'est une belle
performance il est sans arrêt en train
de faire croire aux parents qu'on peut
tout faire on peut s'occuper des enfants
de soignants on peut s'occuper des
enfants des collègues qui sont absents
non remplacés
on peut s'occuper des enfants qui ont le
convie donc des familles du protocole on
doit en même temps donc enseigner enfin
voilà
la charge allez allez exponentielle et
finalement finalement c'est dit on tient
plus
[Musique]